from the worldwide leader in sports
sunday NFL countdowns Charles what's in
good to see you sir
it's always good to see you I'm good I'm
good good to be here with you man
I like the audience Massa nice touch you
know what I appreciate that because
you're a man of the people
absolutely your people person I figured
we'll have people here to listen to our
conversation so what do you think of
this matchup here Charles what do you
think Super Bowl III you know I really I
think it's gonna be a really good game
we really do yeah the Rams were my pick
to win the Super Bowl
back in September so we Michigan men
guys are simpatico pretty small guys I
would say did you have them beating the
Patriots though I had think so I think
about you say that just first and I had
Aaron Donald winning the offensive play
No Oh NFL MVP was the entire league well
he's the best player in football but he
won't get the credit he deserves because
he doesn't score touchdowns you know but
when you think about it when you watch
this man play the game he is doubled
almost 70% of the time and he still came
up with 20 and a half sacks fat think
about that Batman it's a bad man it's a
bad man so when you think about Rams
Patriot you think about offensive teams
you know I thought my reasoning for them
winning the Super Bowl being that this
is such an offensive minded game
nowadays is that defensively the team
that wind would have to come up with the
play similar to last year's Super Bowl
we had a Brandon Graham another Michigan
guy came up with the the second end of
the game to win the game it would be the
same way I feel like this game it'll be
somebody on the defensive side and I
feel like with the playmakers that the
Rams have on their defense that they'll
they'll make the play at the end of the
game to win the game so I'm still going
right I'm still right still going with
the right way around yeah
so what do you think Belichick and
McDaniels and Tom are gonna do to make
sure that Donald - Belichick called
quote-unquote pretty much unblockable
what do you think they're going to do to
prevent that from happening they're
gonna double them they're gonna try to
do what everybody else is you know tried
to do but if you look at Aaron Donald
playing against the Saints they doubled
him you know he didn't have his he
didn't have a sack you know in their
game a couple of weeks ago still
disruptive but he's not sacking the
quarterback so I think that the Patriots
I mean they're gonna do what everybody
else is trying to do in this double-team
you Charles Woodson here on the Rich
Eisen show when's the first time you met
Tom Brady do you remember that I don't
remember the first time but I mean we
came in together you know at the
University of Michigan back in 1995 so
circa 95 so right around then you don't
recall because I guess was he not that
hyped coming into the team or greasy
obviously was the quarterback
well it wasn't it wasn't greasy at the
time I mean he was he was you know
highly recruited but at the time we had
a guy there by the name of Scott drives
by that's right yes who was the guy
Griese was his backup so brady was he
was gonna be waiting his time anyway
because they had two guys there that
were gonna be you know one and two on
the depth chart but you know everybody
asks the question hey what did you see
in Brady you know at Michigan did you
think he'd be this good nobody could
ever foresee Tom Brady making it to nine
Super Bowls but watching him and
watching the way he worked he knew he's
gonna be a good player but with Brady
he's you know like most of the great
players they have something that they
rely upon and he relied upon that chip
on his shoulder you know being taken
late in the draft using that as a
motivation and a motivational factor to
just go out there and outwork everybody
and become the greatest quarterback to
ever play the game
yeah because after you left it was drew
hence
who as we all know was mr. Michigan he
was thrust most hyped athlete to come
out of high school and when he chose
Michigan it was kind of incumbent upon
Lloyd Carr to put him in as a starter
and he wound up getting that but Brady
beat him out again actually and you know
that was a round of time where you know
a lot of coaches were kind of going with
the two quarterback system you know play
one guy you know whether he plays well
or not you bring the other guy in and
you know Henson was a he was the highest
recruit you know and Brady of course had
worked himself into a position to be the
starter but did not you got this young
stud in you're trying to figure out how
to appease him and so they ended up you
know splitting time and I don't I don't
think Brady was too happy about that but
that's part of what what forged the guy
that's now here for nine Super Bowls
rode out about it but like I said you
know the great players you know you used
something you know whatever that may be
what a genius you know what I just I
think I'm kind of self-motivated in a
way I wanted to be great regardless but
if I if I think back if I go all the way
back you know my motivation you know to
be the best that I could possibly be
came from my own household my older
brother was you know he was a star in
our time he played football he ran track
he wrestled and you know people used to
always refer to me as Terry's little
Brit hey you're Terry's little brother
right now man my name's Charles you know
so very early on I kind of had that
drive that I need to make a name for
myself I'm not I'm not
Terry's little brother I'm Charles call
me Charles and so it kind of started
pretty early with me Charles what's in
here on the Rich Eisen show you chose
the Rams to win it all and the Rams are
here and now you're choosing them but
Saints fans we've got Drew Brees coming
up in our three believes the Rams should
not be here at the Super Bowl and you
you know cuz I follow you on twitter you
were pretty vocal at the time about that
call and how and how badly it was blown
you equated it to the Tuck roll moment
for you Charles
you think that's a viable connection
right there yeah thing I think so you
know when you think about it you know
that play you know your people say all
the time doesn't it's not about one play
well it kind of sort of is about one
play because if they make that call
you know the Saints can essentially run
the clock down you know kick the field
goal of course there's no guarantee they
make the field goal but you know all
intents and purposes they make the field
goal game's over
the Saints are in the Superbowl you know
you go back to the Tuck rule if they do
not overturn that call we run the clock
out so we go on to the championship week
you know of course there's no guarantee
that we win the next week but that's an
opportunity you know so for the rest of
their lives this particular team the
Saints there yeah I have to believe that
they believed this was their best
opportunity this team that they have to
win the Super Bowl
well it becomes a missed opportunity and
you never know when you're gonna get
back you know just because you have a
good team one year you know Tom Brady
and the Patriots they're an anomaly that
it just doesn't happen that way the way
they've done it so it's a missed
opportunity for the Saints and it's one
that they're gonna think about forever
and in my tweet I was you know I was you
know pretty much reiterating the fact
that you know people always tell me hey
get over the Tuck rule well listen I
played 18 years in the Football League I
like I got over to tuck rule but I still
think about the Tuck rule like it was a
missed opportunity the Saints are gonna
think about that play for the rest of
their lives because it's a missed
opportunity and they were there's one
play you know that could've ended the
game and got them to the Super Bowl so
it's a you know you hurt for the players
because you know what you know playing
the game you know what you put into this
game you know everybody looks at it and
and it's all you guys are just playing a
game you know it's fun odd this game
takes a toll on you both physically and
mentally and you put a lot into getting
to that point to get to the Super Bowl
and so to have up have an obvious play
not called and it go against you and
it kind of wipes away an opportunity
don't think about that forever so I am
mandated on behalf of New England fans
everywhere including the gentleman to my
left who you know is a New England fan
and also my wife I turned my back to him
no I understand you did that the
difference is is the talk do you not
believe the Tuck rule was appropriately
applied as it was written in the rubra I
do not I do not I feel like it is a
interesting thing about it the way I
think about it mm-hmm so I watch the
news a lot you know a lot of times
you'll have you know two economists went
on television and they'll be talking
about their economy want to say the
economy is doing great and want to say
it's entertained would you like how
these are economists they both have the
same facts and figures same numbers how
can they have differences of opinion
right two plus two is four right mm-hmm
two plus two is four yes correct we're
all in the green right so when you look
at the missed call if you ask a hundred
percent of Saints fans 100 percent of
Rams fan should have have been called
everybody would say yes yes two plus two
is four
and our case two plus two is still four
but they added one so two plus two
equals five why because they were able
to add their own interpretation into it
so they took a play two plus two is four
a fumble
they added their own interpretation and
made it into incomplete pass because
they ruled it a fumble and came back and
looked at it he he's just in the process
of a bring in time what you had able to
take the rule and justify why he
overturned it so if I was so if men you
were in the court of law mm-hmm and
you're arguing that his arm was going
forward I would say well show me the
part where his arms going forward you
would show the tape yusei's arm going
forward and then you'd bring it back and
then I said what tell me when did he
fumble did he fumble white as I was
going forward
and you would have to tell me no he
brought it when he brought it back into
his body
hence the Tucker rule correct yes okay
so was he bringing it back into his body
what was it into his body so there's
there's there's a technicality - hey
look so he's not he wasn't bringing the
ball back into his body
we're not hit him he had it both hands
on the ball it's in his body he ain't
bringing it back into his body it's a
fumble two plus two is four unless you
add one then it's five see I thought you
meant two plus two is five because
that's how many Super Bowls Tom Brady's
I love the fact that he's won five Super
Bowls I'm happy he's still here you know
his mind blowing you know it's funny
Tyler Mike going to the Hall of Fame
yeah and he told me it should be he told
me a story about that night yeah we got
on the air I saw that man you want to
tell that story I saw it man I would
happen after that game with Ty Law
sought you out right Power Man you know
ties
yes I know your Michigan guys oh my god
right you know we lose a game and
everybody's pissed and get on the team
bus leaving the game getting ready to
leave the game and all of a sudden guy
comes up the stairs of the bus hey
Charlie hey Charlie what's up man you
ain't gonna holler at your boy like you
talking about man oh man what you did
man
walks off the bus up I'm livid man
I'm livid I'm like like that's my guy
but man I wonder if I wanted to throw
hands with time man but he just I mean
he rubbed it in my face man and
uh it wasn't it wasn't a pretty sight
well I didn't appreciate he said that
you always would seek each other out
after him
oh and that you did not seek him out so
he was gonna seek you out despite the
fact that it's the Raiders team boss
after that game this man had the
audacity to leave his locker room and
come on our bus after we got robbed no
yeah that took some you know what um
[ __ ] yeah took some gumption audacity
yeah I don't know if I'm still I don't
know if I'm over that either well what's
more what's more audacious him doing
that are you calling out Barack Obama
for not believing in the Packers because
he was a Bears fan well so if he if he
wants the Bears to come to his house
let's go visit him ourselves
Wow I would have to say but it worked
out for you did you ever have a
conversation with him and when you went
to the White House did you see you know
it was uh we only got to see him very
briefly because it was black out
something right schedules are all mixed
up so we actually flew they're on their
way to a preseason game so we got there
and you know he was busy you know trying
to pass a law yeah he's he's a busy man
right so we were in the White House for
like two hours just the team just
hanging out and he was you know
somewhere trying to you know make policy
and he came out briefly we took our team
picture and then we were on a plane
headed to Tampa he didn't call he didn't
call you back out he didn't call you
back out no challenge no challenge
Charles was in some some Tonetta fake I
love it
Charles you the man you're gonna be on
the air a Sunday NFL countdown Samantha
ponder Randy Moss Matt Hasselbeck one of
my favorite people Rex Ryan and you how
long is your pregame show how long is it
you know how long how long
so eight and a half hours how long is
your show somewhere around here if you
double the hours somewhere around four
hours four that's a lot that's a lot of
this is lower but I'm so I'm so happy
that you're you know doing what you do
you seem to be enjoying it immense I'll
do man you're great at you got a special
ass cop picked out for Sunday is you
know Super Bowl Sunday
no no okay very good and I'm trying to
do the math right here are you up for
the whole next year or is it to nurse a
to EEOC I look forward to that day
Charles thanks for coming on this show
man thanks for having you got a had
trouble citizen right here on the rising
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience